[Musique]
avec nous pour en débattre philippe
laurent maire rudy de saut vous êtes
également secrétaire général de
l'association des maires de france
bonsoir philippe laurent merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés pour débattre
valérie boyer à sénatrice l ère des
bouches du rhône
bonsoir valérie aboyer merci d'être avec
nous alors si l'amendement était adoptée
par le parlement ce serait évidemment
une une première dans notre pays le vote
par anticipation serait alors mis en
place pour une échéance très importante
la présidentielle de 2000 22 valérie
boyer on imagine à l'instar de votre
groupe vous allez à voter contre 1 jeudi
demain c'est à dire pour quelle raison
bien sûr que je vais voter contre
demain jeudi et je serai dans
l'hémicycle pour défendre notre point de
vue écoutez c'est choquant sur le fond
et la forme c'est choquant sur la forme
parce que cet amendement arrive en
catimini au décours d'une loi tout à
fait banale sur l'organisation des
élections
c'est choquant sur le fond parce que ça
nous est vendu comme voulant lutter
contre l'abstention or je prends
l'exemple du dernier scrutin
présidentiel
sauf erreur de ma part je crois que 87 %
des électeurs sont allés aux urnes pour
les deux tours ou un détour de la
présidentielle et pour les législatives
donc on voit bien que ce n'est pas le
problème d'abstention pour ce scrutin
ensuite ce qui est choquant c'est que le
conseil constitutionnel à plusieurs
reprises a mis en garde contre les
machines à voter si un moratoire c'est
pas pour rien et nous vendre ça comme un
moyen de lutter contre l'abstention mais
c'est juste de la mauvaise foi un signe
puisque le gouvernement l'a refusée par
l'organisation des régionales et
départementales
donc c'est très troublant de voir à quel
point le président de la république est
sans cesse en train de modifier les
règles du jeu en fait on dirait que ne
pouvant gagner à la loyale
il faut qu'il modifie les règles du jeu
pour s'assurer de sa réélection
et alors il est certain que c'est un
petit peu consubstantiels au maquereau
nisme on se souvient que emmanuel macron
a été élu parce que il n'ya pas eu de
débat sur la présidentielle parce que la
présidentielle a été le débat de la
présidentielle a été volée au français
s'est substituée à ce débat le procès de
françois fillon
donc il a été élu sur cette espèce de
malentendus et depuis on n'a de cesse
que de bouleverser et de désorganiser la
vie politique française sur le plan
institutionnel et même sur le plan
politique et la façon dont cet
amendement a été présenté et son
objectif qui est complètement faux ça
peut peut être pour lutter contre
l'abstention et bien évidemment nous
fait penser à une suspicion de
tripatouillage de magouilles et puis
c'est extrêmement grossier pour les élus
pour le parlement pour les mères qui
sont mis devant un fait accompli
donc il y aurait une centaine de merde
en dedans urbains dans des villes qui
disposerait dans les préfectures d'un
bureau de vote avec une machine à voter
alors sanaryenne moderne la machine à
voter un ca existe depuis les années 60
et ça avait été retiré et puis à les
autres j'allais dire ah les pauvres ceux
qui ne sont rien peut-être les gobeurs
réfractaires qui n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir deux machines à voter qui vont
devoir y aller le dimanche est tous là
voudront pas partir en week-end ou
qu'ils ne prendront pas la peine de
déposer une procuration ou de
s'organiser pour la procuration qui
auront sur la machine à voter c'est à
demander l'avis du maire justement
philippe laurent vous partagez cette
opinion de valérie boyer philippe l'on
va vous redonner la parole vous
inquiétez pas valérie boyer et philippe
laurent vous partager cette opinion pour
vous contre le vote par anticipation
oui alors moi je veux pour mon souvenir
pour les contres pour l'instant ce qui
m'apparaît absolument désastreux est ce
que est ce qu'elle est valérie boyer
d'ailleurs c'est que en réalité tout
ceci a eu ni au dernier moment ça
conserve quand même un élément tout à
fait essentiel sur lequel les maires ou
une responsabilité qui est le vote
l'opération de vote en en elle-même
l'association des maires de france a dit
sa stupéfaction devant cet acte cette
affaire parce que nous n'avons pas été
ni consultés ni prévenu ni quoi que ce
soit c'est venu d'un seul coup comme ça
et je pense d'ailleurs que les sénateurs
eux mêmes ont été assez stupéfait de
cette façon de faire
ça n'est vraiment pas une façon de faire
et je voudrais vraiment souligner un
autre sujet c'est que ça c'est fait pour
l'élection présidentielle
mais lorsqu'il ya eu le débat sur les
élections départementales et régionales
il ya quelques semaines nous avons
proposé l'association des maires de
france
les parlementaires demandent aux
parlementaires ont proposé que soit
remis en vigueur à la double procuration
c'est à dire le fait qu'une qu'un
électeur puisse avoir deux procurations
ça avait été le cas au moment des
élections municipales
on a proposé un certain nombre
d'améliorations au système pour que
précisément ces élections
départementales et régionales puissent
donner lieu à une participation
convenable et ça n'a pas été accepté par
le gouvernement alors vraiment on se dit
que vraiment je vous assure c'est pas
tout de la colère pour pour nous parce
que nous nous disons finalement que du
mépris que veut faire les 10 et que veut
faire le gouvernement
il veut que la participation aux
régionales au départemental de la
majorité présidentielle a quand même de
bonnes chances de perdre
soit le minimum à 1000m le plus la plus
basse possible pour décrédibiliser ces
élections alors même que sur l'élection
présidentielle ont fait tout ce qu'il
faut pour augmenter la participation
dont il ya un vrai sujet moi je trouve
que franchement là on va trop loin
on joue trop avec l'expression
démocratique de nos concitoyens
effectivement c'est un peu sorti du
chapeau et ça fait réagir pas que pas
que vous en savez ressort réagir surtout
les politiques à droite on va écouter
ces réactions vont de vous redonner la
parole
ils n'ont pas le temps d'instaurer la
proportionnelle mais ils ont tant de
magouilles et un vote anticipé pour nous
c'est hors de question
l'élection présidentielle le
gouvernement veut organiser par un
amendement de dernière minute déposé au
sénat un vote dans 100 villes sur
machines électroniques plusieurs jours
avant le dimanche du scrutin
improvisation bricolage graves atteintes
aux règles
mocratique rappelons qu'avant le vote
anticipé sur vos machines à voter les
maquereaux nist avait déjà tenté un coup
de force sur le retour du vote par
correspondance
y compris le 15 janvier par amendement
parlementaire toujours par souci de
notre santé et de la participation bien
sûr alors on vient d'en parler justement
ce côté sorti du chapeau de dernière
minute qui fait réagir mais dans le fond
valérie boyer boyer que recherche le
gouvernement
finalement ça des favoriserait plutôt la
république en marche et ça ferait
peut-être basculé dans les extrêmes
entre guillemets écoutez ça j'en sais
rien mais c'est vrai qu'après le débat
le débat le duo de gérald darmanin avec
marine le pen où chacun et l'assurance
vie de l'autre on voit bien qu'il ya une
sorte de dialogue et d'une de collusion
qui s'installe entre eux mais et mais là
on est dans la politique sur le plan de
l'égalité des électeurs l'esprit de la
vème république c'est la rencontre d'un
homme ou d'une femme
avec le peuple si le s'il n'y a pas une
communion nationale le jour de
l'élection présidentielle comment
voulez-vous faire en sorte que les
français s'intéressent plus à la
politique c'est quand même très
important qu'une fois tous les cinq ans
on puisse se déplacer ensemble pour
choisir qui va être le président de la
république moi je trouve que c'est
extrêmement important
ensuite mon collègue a entièrement
raison sur le fait que ce qu'il propose
là vient de nous être refusé pour
d'autres scrutins par le gouvernement
donc ça suffit les magouilles moi je
pense qu'il est qu'il faut que emmanuel
macron cesse d'abîmer les institutions
on ne peut pas sans arrêt donner des
coups de boutoir au parlement au maire
regardez comment emmanuel macron avait
procédé avec le grand débat en passant
par dessus la tête des maires c'était
pas un grand débat d'ailleurs il n'en
est rien ressorti c'était un grand
monologue suite au fiasco des gilet
jaune qu'il avait provoqué là on est
encore devant un mépris du parlement
puisque on essaye de torpiller
l'examen d'un texte sans présentant de
façon totalement anormal un amendement
qui n'a pas de sens ni pour ni pour
lutter contre l'abstention et qui n'a
rien de moderne puisque c'est quelque
chose qui existe depuis les années 60
comme je vous lisez et que le conseil
constitutionnel recommande de stopper
parce que il y a des suspicions de
fraude et parce que on n'arrive pas de
sécuriser le vote
alors quel est l'intérêt si ce n'est de
jeter du trouble et ensuite comment on
imagine une campagne électorale avec des
gens qui vont s'arrêter le mercredi et
d'autres qui vont aller jusqu'au
dimanche mais c'est pas possible
et pour valérie envoyé le vote anticipé
existe dans plusieurs pays européens on
va les voir huit pays européens
précisément l'appliquent à tous les
électeurs dont le portugal regarder la
suisse le danemark
mais la norvège suède finlande estonie
et lettonie ce il ya quand même des
démocraties là dedans alors pourquoi pas
nous philippe laurent
écoutez chaque pays vous savez à son
histoire démocratique chaque pays a ses
traditions
chaque pays a sa culture démocratique en
france en réalité en france
c'est vrai que l'élection présidentielle
est devenu à un moment de communion
nationale n'ont pas forcément autour des
candidats mais autour de l'idée que
l'ensemble des français donc
et lisez donc ce président de la
république qui a comme vous le savez des
pouvoirs absolument fin très important
peut-être d'ailleurs trop important
maintenant m'enfin c'est autre chose
donc il ya des pouvoirs en tout cas
important mais donc par conséquent c'est
devenu l'élection reine et donc notre
notre démocratie notre république
elle dit clairement cette histoire
culturelle de démocratique elle dit
voilà tout le monde va voter en même
temps à un jour donné il y as si vous
voulez vous le savez avant le second
tour de l'élection présidentielle le
débat entre les deux candidats qui
restent en lice
il ya tout ça ça fait partie voilà tout
à l'heure en général ces images dans le
bruit en retard dans le reportage disent
eh bien voilà
l'élection présidentielle elle se fait
jusqu'au bout il ya des débats il y à
des événements qui peuvent survenir et
donc le vote doit avoir lieu
monde le même jour ou alors il faut
qu'il en est un très grand débat entre
nous ça va prendre du temps mais
pourquoi pas sur tout le système
on peut revoir tout système nous on
n'est pas opposé à ce qu'on discute du
système pour voir est-ce que l'on peut
le modifier mais on peut pas de modifier
comme ça par petits coups qui arrivent
comme sa matinale matutine allemande
comme on dit par un environnement des
gouvernements enfin tout ça est absurde
vous savez un projet de loi ça doit
donner lieu à une étude d'impact ça
c'est la règle si le gouvernement les
gouvernements parce que tous les
gouvernements l'ont fait il faut être
clair a maintenant au dépôt d'un projet
de loi et puis si on va ajouter un truc
enfin un amendement gouvernemental et
certains me demandent de ne pas lieu et
tout impact tout ça ne va pas notre
système système là ne fonctionne plus
plus bien et donc nous les maires qui
sommes sur le terrain des gens
pragmatiques ou bien nous nous voyons
cela
avec un peu de désespérance et comme je
le disais tout à l'heure avec aussi un
peu de colère
tout ça ne va pas on ne va pas
reconstruire la république comme ça ça
sera le mot de la fin pour vous est ce
que ça montre en tout cas une certaine
forme de fébrilité dans le dans le camp
de la macro ni en vue des
présidentielles
pour ce qui me concerne
ah oui je pense que oui parce que si je
vous ai fait tout à leur convient les
propositions très simple que nous avons
fait pour améliorer la situation deux
pas de la participation lors des
élections départementales et régionales
avaient été refusées et pour nous ce
sont des élections aussi qui sont très
importantes être concernent la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens et donc
on ne comprend pas pourquoi tout ça a
été refusé ce moment là puis que tout à
coup on s'aperçoit qu'ils aient des
élections présidentielles qui arrivent
et or très vite il faut modifier les
règles du jeu vous voyez donc fébrilité
de la part du camp microns
la présidentielle et a bel et bien
démarré vérité oui oui fébrilité et
aussi cette méthode comme le disait
monsieur laurent le maire de sceaux qui
consiste systématiquement à modifier les
règles du jeu comme si emmanuel macron
se considérer comme incapable de gagner
à la loyale avec des règles communément
admise en fait il est là pour en sorte
déconstruire la vème république
c'est pas le mandat qu'il a eu des
français est aujourd'hui un parlement il
ya l'union des maires qui s'opposent à
ceux à ce dispositif au sénat tous les
groupes ont voté contre et à l'assemblée
nationale il faut quand même savoir est
rappelé que même dans le camp macro nist
eh bien il ya des députés qui étaient
contre donc un moment donné je pense que
nos institutions surtout dans une
période de grande fragilité comme la
note ça se respecte et que peut-être que
d'autres pays ont mis en place du vote
anticipé mais chez nous l'élection du
président de la république
si ce jour là on n'est pas capable
d'organiser pour tout le monde invente à
égalité avec un débat comme monsieur
laurent vient de le rappeler qu'elle
doit en général le mercredi ou le jeudi
avant avant le scrutin pour que les
français puissent déterminer on sait
très bien qu'ils se déterminent au
dernier moment
et bien c'est qu'on aura encore rater ce
grand moment démocratique écouter on l'a
ratée en 2017
ce serait quand même dramatique qu on le
rate en 2022 une deuxième fois
là on serait vraiment dans une crise
institutionnelle extrêmement forte et
qui serait la responsabilité d'emmanuel
macron donc moi je dis stop à la casse
de la vème république l'élection
présidentielle ça ne se joue pas en
catimini à travers un amendement qui est
déposé en douce pour modifier
profondément la relation du président de
la république avec les français merci à
tous les deux merci à tous les deux
philippe alors on valérie boyer d'avoir
été avec nous merci